Schönen guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ujak. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnese-Gespräch durchführen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich Doktor.
Danke. Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, okay?
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Ingrid Meyerhof.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam bestabieren?
Ja. I, N, G, R, I, D. Ingrid.
Ja.
M, E, I, E, R, H, O, W, F. Meyerhof.
Frau Meyerhof, wie alt sind Sie?
Bitte wieder.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ja. Ich bin 1 und 51 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
18. Juni 1974.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1 Meter 68.
Und wie schwer sind Sie zuzeit?
73 Kilogramm.
Okay. Danke für die Informationen. Frau Meyerhof, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie zuzeit?
Ja Doktor, ich bin heute gekommen, weil ich seit zwei Tagen Rückschmerzen habe.
Wo genau diese Schmerzen, Frau Meyerhof, am Rücken? Ich meine Unterbereich, Oberbereich, Schulterbereich.
Ja Doktor, die Schmerzen sind in der rechten Schulter.
Können Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben? Also sind sie eher drückend, stechend, brennend, dumpf?
Ja, die Schmerzen sind dumpf und brennend.
Okay. Sind diese Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Die Schmerzen sind plötzlich aufgetreten.
Und haben sich die Schmerzen mit der Zeit verändert?
Ja, die Schmerzen sind in der Zeit immer schlimmer geworden.
Okay. Frau Meyerhof, strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Die Schmerzen strahlen nicht irgendwo hinaus, Doktor.
Okay. Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzstelle von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leichten und 10 sehr starken Schmerzen entspricht?
Ja, ich verstehe Doktor. Ich denke, das ist 6.
Okay. Frau Meyerhof, soll ich Ihnen eine Schmerzmittei geben oder können Sie die Schmerzen bis Ende des Sprechs aushalten?
Ich kann warten, Doktor.
Okay. Bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid, wenn Sie ein Medikament benötigen. Okay?
Okay, danke.
Gerne. Gibt es etwas, das Schmerzen verschlimmert oder lindert?
Ja, Doktor. Ich habe gemerkt, wenn ich im Bett liegen und rücken bin, dass die Schmerzen immer schlimmer geworden sind.
Okay. Haben Sie früher eine ähnliche Beschwerde gehabt oder ist das das erste Mal?
Ich habe eine ähnliche Beschwerde früher nicht gehabt.
Okay. Frau Meyerhof, haben Sie gegen diese Schmerzen ein Medikament eingenommen?
Ich habe kein Medikament dagegen eingenommen, Doktor.
Oder sind Sie schon beim anderen Arzt gewesen?
Ich war nicht beim anderen Arzt gewesen, Doktor.
Okay, alles klar. Frau Meyerhof, haben Sie an diesem Bereich die Hautveränderungen gemerkt?
Ich meine Rötung, Schwellung?
Ja Doktor, Sie haben recht. Bei mir sind die Schwellungen, Rötung und Bläschen im betropanen Bereich auffallen.
Okay. Und haben Sie Bewegung, Einschränkung gern? Ich meine, können Sie den Arm einfach anheben oder?
Ja Doktor, Sie haben recht. Ich habe auch, ich kann meinen rechten Oberarm wegen der Schmerzen nicht richtig bewegen.
Okay, alles klar.
Rechts und Oberarm, ja.
Okay. Frau Meyerhof, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Bläschen, Rötung und Schwellung bemerkt?
Ja.
Also darf ich fragen, haben Sie diese Probleme nur in diesem Bereich bemerkt oder auch in anderen Körperregionen?
Nein, nur im betroffenen Bereich, Doktor.
Können wir sagen, ob diese Probleme wie ein Gürtel für mich sind oder?
Ja, ein bisschen, Doktor, Sie haben recht.
Okay. Frau Meyerhof, haben Sie Probleme, die Ihre Immunsysteme verschlimmern?
Ja Doktor, ich hatte vor etwa 10 Jahren Hepatitis B, aber es ging nicht mehr genau.
Mein Mann hat es damals diagnosiert.
Aber ich habe es nicht mehr genau.
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich habe eine Immunsystemprobleme. Ich bin nicht Arzt, Doktor.
Ja genau, Sie haben recht. Frau Meyerhof, nehmen Sie regelmäßig bei Bedarf ein Medikament ein?
Für Hepatis A, oder?
Oder gegen irgendwelche anderen Krankheiten?
Ich weiß es nicht, Doktor. Ich habe keine Migräne. Deswegen habe ich bei Bedarf ein Schmerzmittel.
Ich nehme bei Bedarf ein Schmerzmittel.
Aber zur Zeit nehme ich den Namen weiß ich leider nicht, Doktor.
Okay, kein Problem. Haben Sie eine Medikamentenliste dabei?
Jetzt nicht.
Okay, Frau Meyerhof, wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Ich bin eine Hausärztin.
Okay, dann haben Sie eine Medikamentenliste dabei?
Jetzt nicht.
Okay, Frau Meyerhof, wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Meine Hausärztin ist Frau Meika.
M-E-I-K-E-R, richtig? Meika?
Ja, richtig.
Okay, ich werde Ihre Hausärztin kontaktieren. Machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Danke schön.
Okay, Frau Meyerhof, fühlen Sie sich friedlich?
Haben Sie viel Barstaffrost oder Nachschweiz?
Nein, Doktor, ich habe keinen Nachschweiz. Nein.
Ist Ihnen übel oder mussten Sie erbrechen?
Ich habe keinen Nachschweiz.
Okay, das freut mich.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Ich habe keine Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen.
Super. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Seit zwei Tagen habe ich kaum Appetit.
Wegen dieser Schmerzen oder?
Ja, ja, ja. Schmerzbedingte Appetit, das sehe ich.
Okay, verstehe.
Haben Sie in der Lesezeit unwirklich ab- oder zugenommen?
Ich habe keine Gewicht verloren, Doktor. Ich denke, ich bin immer gleichgewicht.
Super.
Frau Meyerhof, schlafen Sie gut?
Nein, Doktor. Ich habe starke Rückenschmerzen. Ich schlafe nicht gut.
Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Beide.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Leiden Sie unter Husten oder Luftnot?
Ich habe keine Probleme, Doktor.
Okay, alles klar.
Frau Meyerhof, sind Sie schon vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und Covid-Infektionen geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig gegen die Infektionen, Doktor.
Besuchen Sie regelmäßig Ihren Frauenarzt?
Ja, ja, ich besuche regelmäßig, ja.
Und ist alles in Ordnung?
Ja, alles ist in Ordnung, ja.
Okay, wann war Ihre letzte Periode?
Vor drei Wochen, ja.
Okay. Frau Meyerhof, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie seit wann an Migränen leiden?
Ja, es war sehr lange, wahrscheinlich seit 20 Jahren, Doktor.
Okay, und Sie nehmen dagegen ein Schmerzmittel ein?
Ja, ja.
Bei Bedarf?
Ja, bei Bedarf.
Und Sie haben vor zehn Jahren an Hepatitis B gelitten?
Ja, ja, richtig.
Wie wurde dieses Problem behandelt? Stationär aufgenommen oder ambulant?
Nein, nicht stationär.
Ich habe eine Tablette abgenommen, eingenommen, aber jetzt erinnere ich mich nicht, Doktor.
Momentan nehmen Sie ein Medikament dagegen ein?
Nein, momentan nehme ich keine Medikamente ein.
Okay, alles klar. Sonst noch etwas? Irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen haben Sie?
Ich habe keine anderen Erkrankungen, Doktor.
Okay, und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie keine Medikamente außer Schmerzmittel einnehmen, richtig?
Ja, ja, richtig.
Okay, super. Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Operiert worden? Nein, Doktor. Ja, ja, ich habe erinnert.
Als ich sechs Jahre alt war, hatte ich eine Schulteferrletzung auf der linken Seite.
Aber damals wurde sie konservativ behalten, nicht operiert.
Okay, sonst noch etwas?
Das war es.
Okay, haben Sie Allergie gegen irgendwelche Medikamente, Pflanzen, Nahrungsmittel?
Ja, ich habe eine Aspirinallergie.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Davon bekomme ich Atemnot.
Sonst noch etwas?
Außerdem habe ich eine Nikelallergie, die sich mit Juckreis und Ausschlag äußert.
Okay, Frau Meyerhoff, rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche seit 20 Jahren etwa fünf Zigaretten täglich.
Und trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ich trinke keinen Alkohol, aber jeden Abend trinke ich ein Glas Bier, Doktor.
Ich habe meine Nachbarn gehört. Ist ein Glas Bier gut für mich?
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie ein Glas Bier täglich trinken, ja?
Ja, jeden Abend.
Okay, also aus ärztlichen Sicht gibt es keinen positiven Einfluss für Ihre Gesundheit.
Ich meine über Alkoholkonsum, Frau Meyerhoff.
Also ich würde Ihnen empfehlen, das Trinken ein bisschen einschränken.
Okay.
Okay, bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich. Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ich habe keine Erfahrung mit Drogen, Doktor.
Das freut mich. Okay.
Frau Meyerhoff, leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Bruthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit?
Mein Vater ist mit 76 Jahren an Bauchschweize durch Krebs gestorben.
Mein Beileid, Frau Meyerhoff.
Danke schön.
Und Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter hat eine Herzschwäche, aber sie lebt jetzt in Altenheim.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind, Doktor.
Okay. Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich arbeite im Kindergarten als Lehrerin.
Ich meine, wie ist Ihr Familienstand? Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Okay. Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe eine Schwester, eine Tochter.
Okay. Ist sie gesund?
Ja, sie ist gesund, aber sie ist schwanger.
Mit wem wohnen Sie?
Ich wohne mit meinem Mann.
Wohnen Sie auch mit Ihrem Tochter?
Ja, nur mit meinem Mann.
Okay. Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Lehrerin von Beruf sind?
Ja.
Okay. Welche Fachunterrichten Sie?
Ich arbeite im Kindergarten, Doktor.
Okay. Frau Meyerhoff, nur eine Frage über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden.
Also haben Sie Tauchbeizitel, Gefühle oder Kriben in diesem Bereich?
Ja, Doktor, Sie haben recht. Ich fühle mich ein bisschen kribben.
Okay. Das waren meine Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, Doktor, Sie haben gesagt, es gibt Möglichkeit für ein Immunsystemproblem.
Ich habe viel Angst. Was habe ich?
Frau Meyerhoff, machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Das war nur eine Frage. Diese Fragen sind sehr wichtig.
Diese Fragen helfen mir, Ihre Beschwerden besser einzuordnen.
Deswegen stelle ich diese Fragen.
Ich vermute, dass Sie an Gültal Rose leiden.
Das ist eine Krankheit, die durch ein Virus kommt.
Das gleiche Virus macht auch Windbrocken.
Nach dem Windbrocken bleibt das Virus im Körper.
Viele Jahre später kann es weiter aktiv werden.
Dann bekommt man Gültal Rose.
Wir werden sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen.
Dann werde ich ihr Brot abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Sobald alle Ergebnisse da sind, werde ich die weiteren Informationen mitteilen.
Machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Ich möchte sagen, dass Sie als Lehrerin arbeiten.
Das ist ein Risikofaktor für Ihre Studentinnen.
Deswegen sollen Sie zu Hause bleiben, bis alle Lektionen verkrustet sind.
Okay.
Doktor, darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Ja, gerne. Bitte schön.
Vor zwei Jahren hatte meine Nachbarin eine Gültalrose.
Sie haben recht.
Nach dieser Krankheit haben meine Nachbarin viele starke Rückenschmerzen.
Ich bin sehr Angst.
Frau Meyer, es gibt auch ein Risiko für diese Schmerzen.
Aber Sie sind eine junge Frau.
Sie sind 51 Jahre alt.
Wir warten solche Schmerzen bei Ihnen nicht.
Danke schön. Hoffentlich, Doktor.
Bitte?
Hoffentlich.
Ja, genau.
Nehmen Sie Platz im Wartezimmer.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Danke schön, Doktor.
Gerne.
Okay.
Schönen guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne über Sie berichten.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Danke schön.
Frau Ingrid Meyerhof ist 51 Jahre alt.
Sie ist 1,68 Meter groß und 73 Kilogramm schwer.
Frau Meyerhof stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit zwei Tagen bestehender Dosa Schmerzen vor.
Der Patientin zufolge sahen die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten und mit der Zeit immer schlimmer geworden.
Die Schmerzen lokalisieren an der rechten Schulter und seien dumpf und brennend.
Diese Schmerzen würden nirgendwo ausstrahlen.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde auf eine Schmerzskala mit 6 von 10 bewertet.
Die Patienten haben gegen diese Schmerzen keine Medikamente eingenommen.
Die Patientin berichtete, dass die Schmerzen sich beim liegen auf dem Rücken verschlimmern.
Außerdem klagte sie über Ödem, Erythem und Vesicillin.
Sie erwähnte, dass diese Schmerzen güterformig seien.
Sie klagte über Bewegungsanschränkungen.
Bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die Folgenden bekannt.
Sie hatte Schmerzbedingte Inapetenz und Schmerzbedingte Insomnie in Form von Einschlafstörungen und Durchschlafstörungen.
Sie sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und Covid-Infektionen geimpft.
Sie besuchte ihren Arzt regelmäßig und ihre letzte Periode vor 3 Wochen.
An Vorerkrankungen nannte sie seit 20 Jahren bestehende Migräne und vor 10 Jahren diagnostizierte Hepatitis B Infektion.
Sie nehme gegen Migräne ein Schmerzmittel bei Bedarf ein.
Der Name von Medikament sollte geklärt werden.
Mit 16 Jahren hatte sie eine Schulterverletzung, die konservativ behandelt wurde.
Sie hatte Allergie gegen Aspirin und Nickel.
Aspirin Allergie ist durch Dyspne und Nickel Allergie durch Puritus und Exanthin.
Sie war Raucherin und rauchte seit 20 Jahren 50 Grad täglich.
Sie trank ein Glas Bier täglich.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familie Ananese gab sie an, dass der Vater mit 76 Jahren an Pankreaskarzinom verstorben sei.
Die Mutter leide an Herzintensivität und wohne in einem alten Heim.
Sie sei Einzelkind, verheiratet und habe eine schwangere Tochter.
Sie wohne mit ihrem Mann zusammen.
Sie sei Lehrerin von Beruf in einem Kindergarten.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine Herpes-Soster-Infektion aus, da die Patientin typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Die Patientin leidet unter Rückenschmerzen, Ödem, Erythem und Whysicillin an diesem Bereich.
Diese Symptome sprechen für eine Herpes-Soster-Infektion.
Als differenzierte Diagnosen kommen Herpes-Simplex-Infektionen.
Und die Prolapsus oder Muskelentspannung in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich bei der Patientin eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen und die Etapparameter überwachen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob sie Erythem, Ödem, Whysicillin, Pusten und andere Hartveränderungen hat.
Zusätzlich ist eine Laboruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnostik zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Blutbild, CRP, BSG, Valicella-Soster, PCA-Test und Leberwerte, Nierenwerte bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine Röntgenaufnahme durchführen, um eine Verletzung bei den Knochen auszuschließen.
Leider habe ich über Verletzung an einem Nase nicht gefragt, aber nach dem Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch werde ich diese Frage stellen.
Um die Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich die Patienten ambulant behandeln.
Ich würde Antivirant-Therapie wie Asiklovir, Valacyclovir oder Biovidin verschreiben.
Ich würde der Patientin krank schreiben. Ich würde der Patientin empfehlen, zu Hause zu bleiben, nachdem alle Whysicillin und Pusten verkrustet sind.
Und die Tochter der Patientin ist schwanger. Deswegen ist ein Kontakt mit der Tochter ein großes Risiko für das Baby.
Ich würde auch keinen Kontakt mit der Tochter empfehlen. Danach würde ich ein dermatologisches Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie der Patienten zu optimieren.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren.
Herr Kollegen, in welchen Situationen verursacht Herpes-Soster-Infektion?
Imunspressive Situationen können Herpes-Soster-Infektionen verursachen, wie zum Beispiel Katsynoma oder imunspressive Medikamente wie zum Beispiel Corticosteroide oder andere imunspressive Medikamente wie zum Beispiel Methotrexat oder
Azotopirin. Aber die Patienten geben keine medikamentösen Geschichten über sie.
Verursacht Depression diese Krankheit?
Eine Major-Depression kann eine Immunspression verursachen. Deswegen kann das auch ein Risikofaktor sein.
Ja, das kann sein. Es gibt eine lokale Schmerzen bei den Patienten, besonders am Schwerpunkt der Neuralgie.
Das kann sein, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es eine Details zu diesem Thema gibt.
Also ich meine eine interkostal Neurode. Neuralgie.
Neuralgie, okay.
Meinen Sie eine Einklemmung der Nerven oder?
Interkostal Neurode ist eine Neuralgie.
Diese Begriffe haben Muskelschwäche, Zoonososter,
ist der Oberbegriff. Dieser Begriff enthält Muskelschwerheit, Sonazoster, Muskelschmerzen und andere
viele Krankheiten. Es konnte sein, dass es in diesem Fall Myokartinfarkt ist oder Herzkrankleidkrankheiten.
Also die Patientin leidet unter einer Schmerzen, die am rechten Schulter lokalisiert sein. Also keine
Brutschmerzen. Aber ich habe schon über Luftdispneum nicht gefragt. Aber sie leidet unter keine
Brutschmerzen. Also ich denke nicht so. Manchmal verursacht rechte Ventrikelinfarkt, rechte Schulter
Schmerzen. Manchmal auch Oberbauchschmerzen. Und in diesem Fall würden sie eine Thoraxonographie
durchführen. Eine Thoraxonographie, also wir können eine Thoraxonographie durchführen, um die
möglichen mediasinale Pathologien zu beurteilen. Wie zum Beispiel vergrößerte
Hilum, vergrößerte Lymphknoten, wie zum Beispiel eine Sarkoidose oder vielleicht eine Typakulose.
Das finde ich ein bisschen extrem bei diesem Fall. Aber wir können die mediasinale Pathologien
zu beurteilen oder...
Wir können nur mit Hilfe der Ultraschall-Untersuchung weichgewebe Probleme ausschließen.
Oberfläche Proben nutzen wir und wenn der Patient absetzt oder andere weichgewebe Probleme
können wir die Diagnostisierung. Andere Situationen, wenn wir eine Thoraxonographie machen, können wir
Intratorakal Pathologien ausschließen. Wie zum Beispiel Abscess in Prolaspalt, Hämatorax oder
Apilomotorax. Würden Sie in diesem Fall Thorax, Röntgen des Thorax?
Ja, ich würde ein Röntgen des Thorax durchführen, um die möglichen Verletzungen,
besonders mit der Rippen, genau zu beurteilen. Die Patienten gab keine Verletzungsschichte,
aber wir sollen eine Röntgen-Untersuchung durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien zu überprüfen.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall Asyklopher verabreichen?
Ja, können wir Asyklopher anordnen als Therapie. Besonders in 72 Stunden sollen wir eine antivirale
Therapie anordnen, wie zum Beispiel Asyklopher oder Valasyklopher.
In welchem Dosis verabreichen Sie?
Ja, wir sollen 5 mal 800 mg Asyklopher pro Tag oder 3 mal 1000 mg Valasyklopher anordnen.
Oder wir können auch 125 mg anordnen, einmal pro Tag für eine Woche.
Würden Sie jemandem empfehlen?
Also es gibt einen Risikofaktor für die Studentinnen, weil sie eine Lehrerin sind.
Also ich würde empfehlen für die Studentinnen, aber ich glaube,
eine Varesele-Sost-Tersch-Impfung ist ein Standardimpfung in Deutschland oder?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, Herr Oberst.
Ich auch, nicht sicher. Aber empfehlen Sie in diesem Fall kleine Kinder oder
Schwangers, oder wenn jemand in Ihrem Umgebung schwanger ist, empfehlen wir auch Impfungen.
Ich frage eine Aufklärung. Können Sie uns CT des Thorax aufklären?
Ja, gerne. Ich werde Sie über CT des Thorax aufklären.
Computer-Tomographie gehört zu den bildgebenden Verfahren.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, Verletzungen, Erntzündungen, Blutungen, Tumore oder andere Veränderungen
genau zu erkennen.
Diese Untersuchung benötigt nur noch eine geringe Strahlenbelastung und ist völlig schmerzfrei.
Der Patient soll etwa 30 Minuten in einer CT-Röhre liegen und wenn der Patient
einen Platzangst hat, können wir dem Patienten eine Beruhigungsmittel geben.
Diese Untersuchung hat einige Kontraindikationen, wie Schwangerschaft und Kontrastmittelallergie.
Manchmal müssen wir dem Patienten einen Kontrastmittel geben, um die Innerorgane
sichtbar zu machen. Es gibt keine Komplikationen und keine Einschränkungen nach der Untersuchung.
Der Patient kann den Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Vielen Dank, Herr Oberhaus. Sie sind sehr nett.
Der Patient ist ein Intercostal Neuralgiddyl.
Er ist ein bisschen wie ein Üsbegriff, aber es ist ein einziger.
Besonders ist es Gürtelformik.
Es ist wichtig, dass es nicht Gürtelformik ist und nicht im Mittelpunkt.
Ich bin es ein bisschen für einen Dermatologen zu tun.
Wir haben sie schon gefragt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das Immunschwereinigen beantworten kann.
Das ist eine Angelegenheit.
Das können sie vielleicht im Test machen.
Wenn der Patient zonazoster ist, warum wird er zonazoster?
Es gibt keine Grundlage dafür.
Im Cancer oder so.
Es gibt keine Angelegenheit.
Ich denke, es ist eine Angelegenheit.
Ich habe es sogar in der Piole Nefflitte gesagt.
Der Patient wurde gefragt, ob er sich um Immunschwereinigung bewegen kann.
Das sind die Dinge, die du nennen, um zu reden.
Nicht um deine Information zu messen.
Die Dinge, die du nennen, um zu reden.
Du kannst sagen, dass du keine Informationen hast.
Dann kannst du sagen, ich werde es recherchieren.
Okay, ich bin weg.
Timo, bist du bereit?
Ich weiß nicht, wie bereit wir sind.
Wir versuchen es, Hocam.
Es ist besser, nicht zu reden.
Natürlich.
Okay, ich werde es wieder öffnen.
Ich werde es wieder öffnen.
Ich bin ein bisschen verabredet.
Heute haben wir einen neuen Patienten.
Darf ich Ihnen einen Patienten vorstellen?
Ja, bitte.
Wenn Sie aufgenommen würden, wäre es besser.
Was habe ich gesagt?
Aufgenommen ist nicht der Fall.
Sie haben einen neuen Patienten.
Einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen, das stimmt.
Es geht um Frau Ingrid Meyerhof.
Sie ist 51 Jahre alt.
Sie ist 1,68 Meter groß und 63 Kilogramm schwer.
Sie steht heute bei uns.
Sie wegt seit zwei Tagen.
Sie hat dünne Rückenschmerzen.
Die Schmerzen sind dünn und brennend.
Sie hat die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten.
Sie ist im Laufe der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Sie hat die Schmerzen androhicationen Ereignisse.
Außerdem sch reflexioniere die Schmerzen ständig auf.
Aufstandspersonal ori lyingitted Schmerzen und sich
Die Betrophenenbereich bemerkt habe.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde mit 6 von 9 auf eine Schmerzkala bewertet.
Die Schmerzen wurden in anderen Körperregionen nicht ausgestrahlt.
Wegen dieser Schmerzen wurden die Patienten nicht unter den Baumen gebracht.
Sie haben keine Medikamente genommen.
Sie haben die Schmerzen nicht richtig ausgestrahlt.
Die Symptome gehen mit Müdigkeit und schlaftbedingter Insomnie und schmerzbedingter Inapetens einher.
Einher.
Die Anführerkrankungen sind nicht so gut.
Seit etwa 10 Jahren sind die Patienten A oder B nicht gut.
Außerdem haben sie gelegentlich Migräne.
Sie nehmen bei Bedarf eine Schmerzmittel gegen diese Schmerzen ein,
die mit den Wirkstoffen, Dosis und Häufigkeiten noch geklärt werden sollten.
Als die 6 Jahre alt sind, hat sie eine Schulte verletzt auf der linken Seite.
Sie werden konservativ behandelt.
Sie sind allergisch gegen eine Aspirin, die sich mit Atemnot auslöst.
Außerdem haben sie eine Nikelallergie, die sich mit Yükreis und Ausschlag auslöst.
Sie rauchen seit 20 Jahren etwa 5 Zigaretten täglich.
Sie trinken ein Glas Bier jeden Abend.
Drogen konsumiert wurde vernannt.
Sie teilen mit ihrem Vater mit 6 und 7 Jahren Bauchspeise durch Krebs.
Das ist das Schlimmste.
Das ist der Vater, der mit 76 Jahren an Pankreaskarcinoma gestorben ist.
Die Mutter hat leider eine Krankheit, eine Infusion. Sie lebt jetzt und wohnt in Altenheim.
Sie ist Einzelkind. Sie arbeitet in Kindergarten als Lehrerin. Sie ist verheiratet und hat eine Schwester.
Ihre Schwester ist schwanger. Ich gehe von Verdacht auf Herpes-Soster aus, da die Patienten typische Symptome dafür ausweisen.
Die Patienten leiden unter seit zwei Tagen. Sie sind in der rechten Schulter und der rechten Schulta.
Außerdem klagt sie über die exzellente Ödem und Vesikule. Diese Symptome sprechen für Herpes-Soster.
Als Differenzdiagnose kommen auch Interkostalneuralgie, Myokartinfarkt, Erisipel, Urolithiasis und Pyronephritis infrage.
Um meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen, überwache ich die vitalen Parameter und mache eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Ich mache eine körperliche Untersuchung, um zu beachten, ob es eine Ödem, eine Eritem, eine Vesikule oder andere Veränderungen gibt.
Außerdem würde ich Lunge und Herz abhören.
Ich würde eine Laborkonzerstörung durchführen. Dabei würde ich Großblutbild, Entzündungsparameter, Lebewerter, Nierenwerter, Herzensime und Serologie antifizieren.
Danach würde ich einen Urinatest durchführen, um mögliche Nierenkrankheiten auszuschließen.
Ich würde eine EKG schreiben, um mögliche Myokartinfarkt auszuschließen.
Und um mögliche Rippen zu beurteilen.
Und um mögliche Nierenkrankheiten auszuschließen.
Sollte ich meine Verdachtstheorose bestätigen, würde ich die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Ich würde einen Venouszugang legen und eine Flüssigkeit zuvor an der Getüge einleiten.
Und dann würde ich die Patienten aufnehmen.
Ich würde sie fünfmal täglich für sieben Tage schreiben.
Und dann würde ich sie fünfmal täglich für sieben Tage schreiben.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgeheimweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit dem geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren.